and now here's how to take off a girl's  bra using no hands first back to the  basics we all know this one  the old one hander you're in the heat of  the moment and you just have all right  I'm just all right hold on a second I've  done this before  okay new idea the old two-handed take  both hands and glut okay hold on this is  I think it's stuck no no no no no I got  it don't worry I just her bras offer you  haven't used your hands and now you know  for future reference just struggle  admirably until she does it for you  granted we got by on a technicality but  bras off so uh you know really no we're  debating here frankly yeah find a little  unsettling that you're still watching  [Music]